chantal hébert michel sauget alec
castonguay bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
jamais on n'aura autant parler de
voyager des voyageurs et des clous
mesures vis-à-vis les voyageurs je vous
fais entendre monsieur les deux extraits
de la journée là qui résume le dos si
monsieur trudeau qui est ce qu'explique
d'expliquer pourquoi il hésite parce
qu'ils plaident que c'est plus complexe
puis monsieur legault qui revient à la
charge et monsieur x raid ou six qui
revenait à la charge mais on va attendre
mais sur le groupe n'est pas parce qu'on
est déjà des mesures extrêmement fortes
il faut qu'on s'assure que les mesures
qu'on met en plus vont être les bonnes
parce qu'on sait très bien
lina que on dépend de d'avion a qui
viennent de partout dans le monde pour
notre nourriture pour nous bien
pharmaceutiques pour des livraisons de
biens essentiels et on ne veut pas
interrompre les chaînes
d'approvisionnement sur lesquels les
canadiens dépensent on va avoir des
annonces à faire d'ici très peu sur
exactement comment on va pouvoir faire
ça on y travaille avec acharnement
maintenant
parce que monsieur trudeau a tous les
pouvoirs soit pour interdire les voyages
non-essentiels internationaux soit pour
obliger les nouveaux arrivants qui
arrive de vol de l'étranger mais d'être
en quarantaine dans des hôtels
superviser chaque jour il ya des
voyageurs qui arrivent donc à chaque
jour qui passe il ya un risque qui
s'ajoute donc une urgence d'agir
on était un peu dans la même situation
qu'au début du mois de mars et dernière
là où on adepte de la difficulté avec
monsieur trudeau à ce qu'il ya juste ce
rapidement
je commence avec vous avec monsieur
trudeau qui dit grand des nouvelles
mesures mais qualifié d' expliquer que
c'est pas si simple que sur quoi il a
fallu faire plusieurs coups de téléphone
pour essayer de comprendre ce qu'a
essayé de dire aujourd'hui parce que
c'est vrai que c'est possible mais il
l'a très bien expliqué il ya plusieurs
les plusieurs facteurs à prendre en
compte d'abord la santé publique
fédérale pas capable d'arriver avec un
protocole sanitaire qui empêcherait ces
hôtels remplis de voyageurs la en
quarantaine de devenir des gros foyers
d'éclosion
ça a l'air simple modèle australien et
néo zélandais mais à peu près pas de vol
qui atterrissent en australie en
nouvelle zélande le nombre de vols est
très contrôlée alors on est capable et
répartis dans différents hôtels ça pose
pas problème ici au canada on a quand
même présentement des dizaines de
milliers de voyageurs qui sont dans le
sud qui sont partis cet automne
notamment en floride faire c'est l'hiver
on se demande s'ils reviennent tout ça
en même temps en mars où on va les
mettre
comment va s'assurer que les hôtels sur
sécuritaire et ensuite vient le
protocole pour les reports pour les
exercices la surveillance bref beaucoup
de choses à mettre en place tout cela
est faisable mais ottawa on se gratte un
peu la tête à savoir jusqu'où on va et
quand est ce qu'on est capable
d'annoncer tout ça pour que ça se
tiennent alors on retarde de jour en
jour là non ce qui devrait arriver cette
semaine dont michel sauget aller que tu
te fait raison c'est faisable mais c'est
compliqué et le chai le volet de trouver
que c'est pour objectif que toi jusqu'à
faire simple ça va se faire c'est pas
vrai quand on l'est celle ci pour un
sucre et d'eau mais vous savez par
exemple les chaînes d'approvisionnement
il ya énormément pergaud et dans des
vols commerciaux où il a dépassé les 6
vous si vous imposez la quarantaine il y
aura beaucoup moins de passagers
peut-être y aura beaucoup moins de vols
dans les médicaments à 30
l'année passée on disait oui on pouvait
fermer les vols d'air china
alors il faut savoir ce qu'on veut
tout ça se peut c'est compliqué c'est ça
les chantal alors oui comme une chaîne
ne dit pas de passagers par vol
pas de bol trois cargos pas de cargos
pas d'approvisionnement
alors dire en criant lapin j'empêche les
vols peu probable test obligatoire à
l'aéroport davantage probable encore
faut-il trouver des gens produit
s'administre y est les interpréter ça ne
pousse pas dans les arbres on peut pas
on l'a vu avec les forces armées dans
les soins de longue durée les ch et
celle des l'expertisé sanitaire est
limité à l'extérieur des provinces qui
ont déjà les assez plein avec ça quant
aux photos aux débats du mois de mars
quand même pour écrire l'histoire la
relance au québec elle a eu lieu avant
qu'on soit là dedans et j'ai pas
connaissance que au moment de
l'avalanche
monsieur legault disait à justin trudeau
empêcher des québécois deux parties je
vous montre un tableau là parce que
monsieur legault a réussi en
communication politique a installé cette
idée qu'il s'agissait de claquer des
doigts puisque c'est très très très
simple de tout arrêter tout ça il y en a
pas tant que ça les secondes qui
interdisent on le dit australie nouvelle
zélande belgique
il sera lé japon puis japon c'est plus
compliqué que cela il devrait pas de ça
il est à peu près dans cette colonne
ceux qui ont les résurgences ouverte un
pardon belgique les routes sont ouvertes
ou et les routes sont ouvertes mais les
vols non essentiels doivent être les
voyages non essentiels devraient juger
restrictions comme au canada à peu près
comme au canada canada etats unis france
royaume uni allemagne tél
on n'est pas tout seul alors bref alec
jean revient la charge sur la go 1,6
beaucoup indien il s'agissait de faire
claque puis vous êtes hésitant prenez
pas de décisions ça fait de la bonne
politique peut-être mais les faits sont
plus complexes
bon d'abord notre problème actuel de
transmission communautaire du virus
n'ont rien à voir avec les voyages et à
peine 2 % des cas positifs déclaré au
canada qui sont issus des voyageurs dont
98% nos transmissions en rien à voir
avec les voyageurs et les voyageurs on a
l'impression que c'est des touristes
étrangers qui viennent depuis le mois de
mars si aucun résident non
nadine qui peut atterrir au pays c'est
uniquement des canadiens qui voyagent et
qui reviennent au canada donc l'accord
qu'on a elle n'est pas tant sur la
situation actuelle comme ce qui va se
produire dans les prochaines semaines
parce que les variants notamment
britanniques très contagieux faut qu'il
vienne de quelque part il y en a déjà
qui sont entrés ici au canada on a eu
six qu'au québec
mais plus les voyageurs canadiens ils le
répètent vont à l'étranger reviennent
plus les risques augmentent alors il
faut agir pour pas que ça se multiplient
donc la crainte elle est justifiée elle
n'est pas actuelle dans le sens où c'est
pas le plus gros facteur mais ça
pourrait devenir un facteur important
est autant prévenir et sondé conscient
de ça à tahoua fall tous pour le mettre
en place le monde est conscient que la
crainte de d'hautefort de françois
legault qui sont les deux premiers
ministres qui pousse beaucoup là dessus
elle est justifiée c'est pas ce qui
explique ce qui s'est passé depuis
trois-quatre mois là mais c'est ce qui
s'en vient
il faut contenir oui très oui oui michel
un chantage excusez moi je chante non et
on s'entend que il va y avoir des
mesures affectent le but des mesures que
juste un peu de haut va annoncer dans un
monde idéal c'est d'avoir un effet
dissuasif sur les départs plutôt qu un
effet monstre sur les retours c'est à
dire que ce que le gouvernement fédéral
cherche c'est une solution qui a
tellement désagréable idée de partir
qu'on n'a pas besoin de se servir
beaucoup de la solution parce que les
gens vont comprendre qu'il faut qu'ils
restent chez eux
c'est pour ça que plus vraisemblablement
on s'en va vers des solutions qui
impliquent des séjours prolongés à
l'hôtel aux frais des uns et des autres
que l' inverse
néanmoins l'idée de la santé publique
fédérale qui dit attention là il faut
qu'on trouve quand même une formule pour
que ça devienne pas des grandes
croisières
c'est légitime aussi et c'est pour ça
que quelque part c'est pas juste de la
politique est un petit peu de démagogie
très bien est ce que monsieur trudeau un
tour de table rapide je veux passer au
vaccin à l'approvisionnement qui peut
être menacée si monsieur trudeau
expliquer plus clairement la baie
d un de ces dossiers là est ce que ça
serait pas plus simple ils
s'exposeraient moins à se faire dire
j'étais hésitant vous êtes moore sais
pas ce que vous faites je retourne au
tour de tabac lundi tout à l'heure on a
fait beaucoup de téléphones nous aussi
puis moi on a parlé des spéciales et
pascale auclair ce matin là c'est pour
la première fois que j'étais un tribut
au clair dans ses explications là on
peut pas se dire que c'était un
communicateur hors pair quand c'est pas
scriptés là c'est pas quelqu'un qui est
un bon vulgarisateur contrairement à
d'autres premiers ministres ce koh seah
fait pas exception ceci dit quand les
devants rideau hall de boue qui parle à
la nation sans faire bouger dans tous
les détails c'est aussi un peu complexe
wii mote accord devrait accompagner sa
de briefing technique avec des gens qui
s'y connaissent pour nous expliquer
c'est quoi les difficultés parce que
clairement c'est peut-être pas le
premier ministre qu'il faut qu'ils
fassent ça dans son point de presse mais
clairement à ottawa actuellement un
manque de communication qui fait qu'on
laisse beaucoup de glace politique aux
autres premiers ministres notamment dr
dit francis vidal oui
non mais c'est passionnant et manque de
communication le fait est que le
politique au cabinet fédéral a progressé
autour de solutions on sait pas si le
conseil des ministres prières ont réussi
à faire la même chose mais l'impression
qui s'en dégage c'est qu'à la fin il a
de ce qu'on appelle le corps la décision
est dans les mains du premier ministre
et pour ça il faut qu'il réconcilie les
la table du conseil des ministres
donc c'est vraiment difficile
d'expliquer ce qu'on n'a pas encore
conclu en face de son propre cabinet et
c'est là qu'on est pas ce que est ce que
c'est normal autour de la table d'un
conseil des ministres qu'on entende faut
juste des gens qu'ils aient joué oui on
va faire plutôt que b
dans ce cas-ci entre la santé publique
le cabinet altérité coville bien une
variété d'opinions qui ont été exprimées
ok conclusions lundi michel d'une part
monsieur trudeau et pour un bon mec c
est pas bon pour expliquer il est bon
pour faire des choses qui touche à
l'émotion n'est pas bon pour expliquer
le fait qu'aucun des faits compliqué des
faits concrets mais qui demande beaucoup
d'explications et l' on le voit très
clairement d'autre part c'est un fait il
ya l'idée de diviser mais c'est induits
par la décision
et là il commença
souvenir qu'on disait pas le marquer
mais sur des tueuses là qui était je me
balade pas de décision si ça continue on
va sortir la caricature le pôle mater je
vous fais entendre monsieur trudeau sur
les vaccins beaucoup de questions
là-dessus ce matin parce que là la
commission européenne commence à dire et
à plaider
on va les garder pour nous les vaccins
d'abord puis on va envoyer ensuite aux
autres pays ont fait des pressions sur
fight the entre autres on écoute
monsieur trudeau est un extrait de
monsieur legault également il est entré
de communiquer avec nos partenaires en
europe pour s'assurer que les contrats
signés par le canada soit respectée je
comprends qu'il ya certaines
préoccupations politiques par rapport à
certains vaccins et certains pays
pour l'instant le canada n'est pas
compris dans ses préoccupations de
l'europe et nous allons continuer de
travailler avec nos alliés on est encore
confiant à d'abord cessé ce million de
doses pour la fin mars et est de pouvoir
vacciner tous les canadiens qui veulent
se faire vacciner en septembre d'ici
septembre 2021
non toutes les provinces accepter que ça
soit le fédéral qui négocie avec les
fabricants des vaccins compte on est
tous inquiet actuellement nous vaccin
viennent de l'europe ne semble pas
pouvoir venir des états unis on a vu la
sortie de la présidente de la commission
européenne qui dit faudra garder les
vaccins fabriqués en europe pour les
pays en europe donc c'est très
inquiétant
voilà chantage 3 avec vous un vrai sujet
d'inquiétude pour monsieur trudeau ce
soit d'abord on va régler un dossier si
le canada fait pas le poids
c'est moi dans ces négociations alors
c'est pas une grande concession
on l'a laissé négocié l'achat des
vaccins monsieur camille en alberta
vérifier s'il pouvait les acheter
lui-même et c'est à dire par tous les
experts nous mais c'est à hydrogène
premièrement deuxièmement le canada
semble être pris quelques parle dans une
chicane entre l'union européenne spa
d'europe
l'union européenne et le royaume uni
celui qui vient de la quitter et l'idée
que les compagnies pharmaceutiques
continuent à provisionner comme prévu le
royaume uni qui viennent quitter tout le
monde amène des doses qui était prévu
pour l'union va faire donc c'est pas
nécessairement un une chicane canadienne
je note néanmoins dans la déclaration de
ce trou d'eau qui dit on est encore
confiant tessa c'est le mot encore qui
accroche un peu totalement qu'ils
nommèrent doute parce que quand on a
écouté ça ce matin en dessous ça être
alarmés pleurant sur le tapis il a
exprimé quand même il doit 0 faudrait
pas que ça devienne plus gros ce nuage
de l'union européenne michel non on
impose qu'on entend de l'union
européenne d'un autre côté c des
compagnies bien établi qu'on connaît
avec lequel le canada fait des affaires
pour autre chose que le vaccin qui ont
signé des contrats avec le canada alors
un moment donné il ya la concurrence
dans ce monde-là de la pharmacologie
donc à un moment donné c'est pas
nécessairement
avantage de fraser de dire l'eau
excusez-nous canada mais on va donner sa
l'union européenne en même temps faut
voir quels sont les pouvoirs réels de
l'union européenne les empêcher de
remplir un contrat dûment signé un sport
sûr que ça non plus dans les accords de
libre échange et et internationaux que
ça puisse se faire facilement que ça
faut qu'on livre en hurlant jacques oui
à les émissions il ya une opinion
publique aussi en europe qui veut être
assuré et c5 et des âmes
et pour ce qui est des états unis
ça a été clair depuis le jour 1 avant
même que le vaccin ne soit conçu il
allait se servir avant et merci bonsoir
dans le cas de ce qui vient d'europe
c'est qu'il ya des contrats signés entre
le canadien fait il de votre entreprise
avec dans le code moderna il ya pas
beaucoup de danger le vaccin produit aux
états unis donc à moins que joe biden
décide lui aussi de restreindre les
exportations ça devrait aller c'est
surtout le bianco de faïza où le vaccin
est produit en belgique qu'on a des
petits doutes
michel a raison sur le dernier point
qu'il a abordés ici il ya beaucoup de
politique là-dedans l'union européenne
elle est franchement en retard dans son
registre campagne de vaccination les
pays européens on peut commencer avec
sin en décembre comme en grande bretagne
au canada ou aux états unis on vient à
peine depuis deux semaines d'accélérer
la campagne il ya beaucoup de pression
sur des pays en disant comment ça se
fait qu'on est à ce point en retard
alors il ya clairement là une volonté de
montrer qu'on fait quelque chose on
semble le dire aux canadiens qui sait
peut-être le vaccin d'astrazeneca oxford
qui visait d'abord par la commission
européenne
on a des contrats d'approvisionnement
avec astrazeneca dont le toujours pas
approuvé par santé canada
donc ça serait peut-être au deuxième
trimestre comparé des problèmes
d'approvisionnement mais pour ce qui est
des heures pour l'instant pour l'instant
ça tient la route
modern a aussi ses les deux seuls
vaccins qu'on a approuvé hier pour le
premier trimestre ça semble tenir la
route
mais je pense qu à tahoua on a commencé
à envoyer quelques messages dans les
ambassades et excusez moi à la classe
parce qu'en fait huit fois qu'on voit la
personne se faire vacciner
désolé j'ai pas remarqué patrice je ne
suis pas ce que je pense aux gens aussi
qui nous écoute mais c'est ok pour
l'instant on a mis assez rassuré mais
qui provoque les ambassades et consulats
canadiens surveillent cette preuve qu'on
a envoyé le message à nos alliés
européens de ne pas nous oublier dans ce
contrat
cannes britannique la canette union
européenne grande bretagne parce qu'on a
besoin de ces vaccins on a besoin
puisque accouchement qu'on veut vivre
ok personne la possible avenir en région
c'est une bonne idée oui non c'est une
bonne idée de des confiné des endroits
où il ya beaucoup moins de cas au québec
chantal c'est un peu inévitable la vraie
question c'est est-ce que vraiment des
vacances
si on va à la hausse oui michel
je pense que les régions veulent des
copines et piller les ils ont besoin
d'ouvrir certains commerces
cela dit je pense pas que chez les
cowboys même des barrages pense qu'on va
additionner déjà plutôt que d'avoir j'ai
été clair avec jeu désolé 2g deux prises
contre vous je me reprends
l'entraînement
la prochaine fois merci à vous trois
fallu pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici r d